all right welcome back everybody okay so
there's a couple things I want to do
today the first thing is I'm going to
talk just briefly about the second
homework to clear up a couple of
questions that I've been seeing a lot
and then I'm also going to solve the 2d
Laplace equation for equilibrium heat
distribution on a square okay okay good
so on the homework I just wanted to
clarify a couple of small points first
of all when I say to write a MATLAB code
to approximate this integral by you know
in MATLAB I really mean this finite I'm
sorry this infinite real valued in a
girl not the the weird contour complex
integral if you do the complex contour
integral that's fine I don't know how
you would do it but you can you can
integrate this one by hand in MATLAB
just assume like a negative large lower
bound to a positive large upper bound
like negative ten thousand to ten
thousand with a DX of 0.1 or 0.01 and
you'll get something out that's pretty
close to the answer
you'll recognize like PI or some
multiple of Pi popping out okay make
sense someone shouldn't be as hard as
some of some of you've been making it I
know this is a little unclear so I
apologize and there was also did
everyone get the email about the typo in
the second problem this should be e to
the I theta plus e to the minus I theta
naught Z okay so that should make it way
way way easier okay I think that's it
that's all the clarifications were there
any questions about this homework
the third one what news special
conditions reason the ones I solved I
didn't need to I didn't solve all three
of them at least not like formally I
don't think you need them probably okay
okay good so just so that we know I'm
curious when is the midterm oh really
that seems soon Wow okay so the midterm
comes out next Wednesday fantastic and
it'll be due on Friday and I will be out
of town most of the following week after
that so I'll be in for the Monday
lecture but I'll be in Germany on the
Wednesday and the Friday after the
midterm and so I'm gonna have my TAS
give like a midterm solution session
probably the Wednesday after the fourth
or maybe the Friday after the sixth
whatever I'm not sure okay so everything
this week will be on the midterm that's
really next week this is the end of
January okay so everything from this
week will be on the midterm everything
else will not and I guess I owe you a
third homework and I'll probably try to
put it up sometime over the weekend okay
good
any other questions about kind of course
logistics before we jump into math okay
so solving the Laplace equation in 2d is
a pretty good exercise first of all it's
it's a differential equation that
actually useful this is something that
you know a lot of differential equations
that you solve are so restricted or so
there's so many assumptions that it's
hard to see how they can actually be
useful but solving the heat equation for
an equilibrium heat distribution on you
know some kind of an object actually is
physically relevant and this example
it's gonna be a little bit long it's
almost certainly going to go past today
and a little bit into Friday but there's
going to be a lot of extremely important
concepts that come up through the
solution of this Laplace equation so
this is going to motivate like whole
weeks of stuff that we're gonna learn
you know in the next couple of weeks all
right so this is really really important
stuff I've decided to change my boundary
conditions a little bit because I worked
it out this morning and my boundary
conditions are like the worst ones you
could choose so so we have this square
or this rectangle say you know x equals
0 to L y equals 0 to H and I had top and
bottom temperature distributions are
fixed at 0 we have a you know laplacian
of u equals 0 on this this plate or this
rectangle and originally i had a
temperature distribution over here but
it's way easier if i make this left
boundary condition 0 and I put my
temperature distribution here on the
right okay it's not like a huge deal
it's just I don't want to I don't have
to skip a bunch of steps at the very end
and this is a little bit more obvious
what the math is so you could switch
these and the math will get a little
little little bit hairier at the end so
I'm doing it this way is that ok with
everyone ok
all right good so we're going to solve
this problem using the method of
separation of variables which most of
you are familiar with and how many of
you are familiar with the Fourier
transform or Fourier you know series
okay a few of you so the method of
separation of variables really is where
Fourier transforms come from this is why
we do Fourier transforms in the first
place so I'm hoping to show you
something kind of new and interesting
that you might not have known about
separation of variables so we will use
the method of separation of variables
this is one of the most important things
I'm going to teach you in this quarter
all of the things that you're going to
learn this is probably one that you're
going to remember for the longest and
you know just the intuition of how to
handle the separation of variables is
going to be extremely powerful you'll be
able to read arrive basically everything
I'm doing in the second half of this
quarter if you know what's going on here
the basic assumption is that we're going
to assume that our function U so u as a
function of x and y so we're going to
assume that U of X and y can be broken
up into some function which is purely in
terms of x times another function which
is purely in terms of Y so this is some
big f of X times some big G of Y this is
a huge assumption this is not a small
assumption right this is a big one and
we're gonna get to why we would possibly
assume that this is true
later this is not obvious why this would
be true that you could decompose your
function into you know some function of
space times some function of you know x
and y but this is the basic assumption
this works for tons of problems at least
where your coordinate system really is
nicely broken down into X's and Y's okay
so if this was rotated then this
wouldn't be true at all
but I could always rotate my coordinate
system so that it is true okay so we're
going to make this assumption and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
plug this in to Laplace's equation so
Laplace's equation is partial squared
you know u xx plus uy y equals zero so
we're gonna we're gonna use Laplace's
equation so we're going to use del
squared u equals zero and we're gonna
use our boundary conditions to find f of
X and G of Y okay pretty easy to state
what we're doing we're just assuming
that there's some XY separation of the
solution there's some function of x
times some function of Y and then we're
going to use Laplace's equations and the
boundary conditions that we have to find
what F and y have to be and the nice
thing is that by doing it this way we're
going to get ordinary differential
equations to solve for F and G which is
really really special because we know
how to solve this okay if there's any
questions at any point like interrupt
this is super important okay alright so
let's take this equation and plug it in
here so what is the partial of this with
respect to X okay so f x times G right
what's F double what's the double prime
of this with respect to X just F X X G
and the second derivative of this with
respect to Y F times G UI Y okay
that's Laplace's equation in this
separated variables okay pretty
straightforward
now the the trick here it's not really
much of a trick is to move
I'm going to move this term over to the
right and then I'm going to divide all
of the I want all of the functions of X
on one side and I want all of the
functions of Y on the other side okay so
I'm gonna try to get something like FX X
divided by F equals minus Gy Y divided
by G okay I just move this over and I
divide both sides by F and I divide both
sides by G okay so this is purely a
function of X purely a function of G
okay this is great what has to be true
if I have some function you know I have
some function Q of x equals some
function P of Y what has to be true of
both of those functions they can be 0
they can be 0 everywhere they have to
equal a constant it can't equal x
squared and it can't equal sine of Y it
can't equal just a function of X or just
a function of Y it has to be a constant
for this to be true okay so probably the
key part of the separation of variables
is that you have these two expressions
both equal a constant this is really
really really important okay
any questions about why this is true
this makes sense does this not make
sense to anyone I mean this is the thing
that is the most confusing about
separation of variables the first time
around is why this has to equal a
constant but you know just try it out
trying to imagine any function that that
is not a constant and this can't
possibly be true okay this method was
invented
who knows who invented separation of
variables and he guesses not for you
it's older than for you good guess oh
come on sir throwing out names Euler
Newton no Newton not leading this but a
follower of Leibnitz knockouts anyone
else not Koshi not riemann what about
Bernoulli this is such an
underappreciated mathematician there's
like four Bernoulli's okay so this was
invented by Jacob Bernoulli in 1690
that's really old okay so in 1690 a
hundred years before Fourier this basic
idea came into existence by Bernoulli
and he was using it to solve a problem
called the isochrone problem that's
quite interesting and I would bet good
money that this is exactly where Fourier
got the idea to have a Fourier transform
he formalized the solution of this
problem and came up with Fourier
transforms a hundred years later okay so
this was around for a long time before
people got the idea so it's not obvious
what we're gonna do at least it's not
obvious to me all right so a lot of
stuff in math comes out of nowhere but
these things took hundreds of years to
come out of nowhere all right so don't
feel like you're just not getting
something that makes you stupid right it
took the smartest people in the world
hundreds of you
to figure this stuff out okay so we have
this basic equation for separation of
variables and what we're going to do is
essentially we're gonna solve these
different differential equations we're
going to take that function just of x
equals a constant and we're going to
solve that differential equation and
we're going to solve this function just
of y equals the constant and we're gonna
solve that differential equation and the
nice thing about these are that they're
both ordinary differential equations and
we actually know how to solve ordinary
differential equations okay so let's
let's just write this out so f XX / f
equals minus g YY / g and usually the
convention is to call that constant just
lambda we're gonna use lambda just like
we did in ordinary differential
equations it's just some number lambda
okay and so our first OD e is just FXX
equals lambda F so there's an ordinary
differential equation this is just a
function of x equals lambda times that
function this is f double prime equals
lambda f OD okay awesome because we know
how to solve Odie's and we have a couple
of boundary conditions we have f of 0
equals f of sorry f of 0 equals 0 and f
at l equals this little function f of y
so right
the second boundary conditions a little
weird we're going to come back to this
one later so let's ignore that one for
now okay so this is o de 1 for f of X
and o de 2 is also pretty simple we have
gy y equals minus lambda G and these
boundary conditions are much much
simpler we have G of 0 equals G of L
equals 0 G of H good thank you right so
this G equation right any of any of this
Y varying part of the function it has to
be uniformly zero at at y equals 0 and
uniformly 0 at y equals h ok and my F
function has to be uniformly 0 at x
equals 0 and it has to be something else
to satisfy this condition at x equals L
and that's going to be the last step is
satisfying this boundary condition now a
couple of interesting things Laplace's
equation is solved for every lambda you
can name for any number lambda Laplace's
equation is going to be solved by these
two oh DS ok this came from Laplace's
equation but the boundary conditions are
only satisfied for special lambda ok
there's only some special lambda that
will satisfy our boundary conditions
when's the last time we saw special
lambdas coming up I ghen values eigen
lambdas ok so these are gonna play
exactly the same role as eigen values
but in this partial differential
equation I mean these are basically
eigen values of our of these o DS
they're gonna play the same role so
these special lambdas we're gonna use
them to satisfy these four boundary
conditions ok
any questions so far we've separated our
variables plugged it into Laplace's
equation we get two OD es and I'm
telling you that this there's only
solutions that satisfy our boundary
conditions for certain special lambda
okay so I want to give you the big
picture before I actually go into the
nuts and bolts so the big picture is the
following so the first thing we're going
to do which of our boundary conditions
are simpler the the you know the G
boundary conditions are way way way
simpler okay so the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna solve we're
gonna solve Oh de 2 for G of Y and we're
gonna solve Oh de 2 for G of Y and since
these boundary conditions are simple
we're gonna find out what lambda has to
be to satisfy these boundary conditions
so and find lambda that satisfy BCS okay
so what kinds of solutions are there to
these basic equations these are like the
our favorite Oh des we actually know how
to solve these these are linear second
order ode Eva's what kind of solutions
can we get for these types of equations
exponential functions and sines of
cosines so for example if lambda was
positive I'd get sines and cosines
popping out of here if lambda was
negative I get Exponential's popping out
of here ex unstable and stable
Exponential's so to satisfy my boundary
conditions of my function being zero at
the top and bottom what kinds of
functions do I want sines and cosines
Exponential's can't possibly be zero at
two places they're not zero anywhere so
I need sines and cosines and in
particular I need signs signs have lots
of zeros on their period right they
start at zero they end at zero so the
I'm telling you the answer to this story
before actually deriving it but the
solving od2 for lambda
we're going to find that G of Y are
signs and so lambdas have to be positive
numbers where they have a whole period
between 0 and H okay like some harmonic
sign between 0 and H so lambda is going
to be n PI over H squared for positive
wave numbers n and this is easy to
visualize right if I have my boundaries
0 and H to have this be uniformly 0 on 0
and H I need my functions of my
functions of Y to look like signs and
not just any signs but signs that have
exactly a period which is you know an
integer fraction of H ok this is purely
based on physical intuition right we
know that we have this boundary
condition we know what types of
solutions were going to get and so I'm
just guessing I'm gonna have to have
signs and the only way I'm going to have
signs that satisfy these boundary
conditions are for exactly these lambdas
okay we're going to go through all of
the gory details and
actually solve this by hand I just want
you know this is you should be able to
kind of predict what your solution is
going to look like before actually
working out all the math that's the
interpretation part of this okay so step
one is the easy part we solve this OD E
and then we find conditions on lambda
such that this is satisfied these are
the conditions on lambda and then we use
these lambdas we use these special
lambdas in OD e 1 and we're using these
to find our F eigen functions the eigen
functions of this OD e so now I'm
starting to introduce some new language
we are dealing with eigen functions now
so lambdas are still our eigen values
but now solutions of this o de are
functions these are going to be my eigen
functions they're going to turn out to
be orthogonal functions which is nice
and you guys have already told me if
these lambdas are positive these are
going to be sines and cosines these are
going to be Exponential's write e to the
plus lambda is e to the minus lambdas
and if you add those up in the right way
these are going to look like cinches ok
and the last thing we're going to do is
find the coefficient of these I the
coefficients of these eigen functions
for each lambda that satisfy this nasty
boundary condition ok so that's the big
picture we took Laplace's equation we
get two OD es and we have to pick
lambdas eigen values of these OD G's
that satisfy our boundary conditions and
from those lambdas we find our eigen
functions G and F any questions
I'm gonna erase the left board slowly
because I want there to be questions at
this point yeah
fast forwarding the basic idea is that
I'm going to get stuff like e to the
lambda these are functions of X I mean I
get something like e to the lambda X you
know some constant plus some other
constant e to the minus lambda X these
are really route lambdas and it's going
to turn out that these constants are
going to be equal and opposite so I get
something like e to the you know root
lambda X minus e to the root you know
minus root lambda X and this is to cinch
root lambda X so this is just from
remember when we were doing complex
variables this is just how we define
since it's e to the lambda X minus e to
the minus lambda X divided by 2 okay so
when we satisfy our boundary conditions
we're gonna find that these have to
balance each other and we get cinches
popping out and no cut no cautious just
inches which is misleading because this
is not a cinch all right so that's a
good question I was just fast-forwarding
because I want you to know the big steps
that we're doing we're gonna solve for G
and lambda and then we're gonna use
those to solve for F and this is going
to lead to Fourier series which is
really really important okay so yeah
yeah if you have better initial
conditions boundary conditions for F I
would solve at first my choice of which
of these is negative is completely
irrelevant
I could call F hat negative f of X and I
could make my function negative and make
this the negative one and this the
positive one this lambda is true for
positive lambda negative lambda
imaginary lambda root 5 lambda Pi Lambda
whatever like this part Laplace's
equation is true for all lambda and then
you find out that to satisfy these
boundary conditions lambda has to be
positive if these were the simple
boundary conditions then you would find
out to satisfy these boundary conditions
lambda would have to be negative right
so get signs up here so it nothing
changes it's just just like a relabeling
of X's and Y's okay good really good
questions any others
slightly faster than I intended to all
right so we have G y y equals negative
lambda G and we have G 0 equals G H
equals 0 so there's lots of cases I told
you I already gave up the whole story
and I told you lambdas have to be
positive they have to be very special
positive numbers there's not just any
positive number will work but let's try
to see if we can derive this from
scratch ok so the first case we're going
to look at case one this is interesting
interesting and this is for lambda
greater than zero
okay I'm gonna work this out in gory
detail so assume this is just like what
we did for Odie's this is an OD problem
like in 564 so we're going to assume
that G of y equals e to the Alpha Y so
what's second partial derivative of G
with respect to Y okay so gy y equals
alpha squared e to the Alpha Y I plug
those both into my differential equation
I get alpha squared plus lambda e to the
Alpha y equals 0 e to the alpha Y can
never be 0 at least for you know
positive alpha and this thing has to be
0 so alpha equals plus or minus I root
lambda are the only these are the
solutions to this differential equations
and like we expected we get sines and
cosines out for lambda positive we get
you know e to the I root lambdas and e
to the minus I root lambdas and they
give me sines and cosines ok so we have
G of y equals you know some constant K 1
times Coast's root lambda where a
function of Y root lambda y
Plus k2 sign of roots lambda Y and
there's an eye out here I Ketu lambda
sine root lambda Y and I'm going to
choose my constants so that I get a
real-valued sign out because that's the
only way I can satisfy my boundary
conditions so we're going to choose k1
and k2 so the G of Y equals sine of root
lambda Y if you're really interested in
this and I think this is probably a good
exercise try to see if you can satisfy
the boundary conditions if you don't
make this assumption that you just get a
sine root lambda Y try to satisfy the
boundary conditions with this cosine
term and what you're gonna end up
finding is that you can't do it first of
all and if you try if you would end up
shifting your cosine until it looked
like a sine okay okay so this is the
basic form of the function if lambda is
positive and what possible lambdas can
we choose so that our boundary
conditions are satisfied okay so we have
sine of root lambda Y is G of Y and so G
of zero equals zero is easy to satisfy
every single lambda that's positive
satisfies this right and in fact that's
the reason that you need used to be
sines and cosines because no cosines
satisfy this ever but the G of H equals
zero is a little bit nastier so that
means sine of root lambda H has to equal
zero which basically means that this
thing has to be some multiple of pi
okay so this thing has to be some n n
times pi for some integer n right like
this is only going to equal zero if this
thing equals n times pi not PI over two
not PI over four but zero PI 2 pi 4 PI 3
PI whatever okay and so we can finally
say you know root lambda H equals n pi
so lambda equals n PI over H squared ok
this this is my solution in general but
the only lamb doesn't satisfy these
boundary conditions are these countably
infinite lambdas for n equals 1 2 3 4
and so on okay in the notes I go through
some detail and I talk about the other
cases which are also interesting but
less useful so case 2 is when lambda is
strictly negative and when lambda is
strictly negative what kinds of
solutions do we get to this equation
we've already talked about this e to the
plus root lambda Y is an e to the minus
root lambda wise and or the basic idea
here is that we get exponential
functions
and they can never satisfy boundary
conditions they can never satisfy these
boundary conditions okay so we're gonna
throw away all lambdas that are negative
we're gonna go throw away basically all
lambdas except for these very special
countable lambdas I say countable
because there's infinitely many of these
lambdas and you can count them all
okay this maybe this makes sense we're
solving functions of G the only way they
can satisfy our boundary conditions is
for them to be sines and cosines because
we all just signs just signs of these
lambdas because the alternatives are
cosines which don't satisfy this
boundary condition Exponential's which
don't satisfy either boundary conditions
or signs of other lambdas which don't
have this right boundary condition being
true okay so our boundary conditions
have dramatically restricted the space
of possible solutions to our
differential equation this is basically
it okay these two things these are the
only solutions of G that satisfy my
boundary conditions okay I told you that
was the easy part but it's not it's not
like the other parts really hard so now
we're gonna use these lambdas and we're
gonna plug them into our F equation and
we're going to solve for our eigen
functions in X that satisfy our expound
recondition notice that we've taken our
PDE and now we're just solving a bunch
of OD e problems this is awesome we know
how to solve OD es we're really really
good at Odie's and so this general
procedure is a huge simplification of
the problem okay so now we solve FXX
equals lambda f+ lambda f for the
special lambda which are PI n over H to
the power two for N equals one two three
four dot dot
and I'm just going to write this out
long way so this is FXX equals n PI over
H squared times F now you can do the
whole Oh de thing either alpha X I'm
going to spare you the details
this thing has solutions what are the
solutions f of x equals what okay
they're Exponential's Exponential's of
what e to the plus n PI over H X there's
some constant out here plus another
constant e to the minus n PI over H X
those are the solutions right I could
solve my characteristic equation for
this OD e and I would get that my eigen
values are plus and minus and PI over H
those are positive numbers so I get
Exponential's in those unstable and
stable eigen value amounts okay so from
the left boundary condition now like
these are the solutions of my f
functions they're Exponential's so from
our left boundary condition what is our
left PC tell us the boundary condition
is 0 on the left this is the reason I
chose to pick my boundary condition 0 on
the left because this is a huge
simplification so f of 0 has to be 0
everywhere
what's eetu the 0 or e to the minus 0 1
so a n plus BN equals 0 f of 0 equals 0
implies B N equals minus a n awesome and
so what that means is that this is
a and e to the N PI over H X minus e to
the minus n PI over H X this is to cinch
of this to a and cinch and PI over H X
awesome that's our function f of X
equals this satisfies Laplace's equation
definitely satisfies my left boundary
condition the eigen values that I've
chosen are able to solve my Y boundary
conditions I haven't sold my right
boundary condition that's the last thing
we have to do but we're in pretty good
shape we have f of X and G of Y so in
principle we have our solution to this
entire Laplace's equation you
okay this is about to get exciting to me
because we're very very close to writing
down something that looks just like a
Fourier transform okay so the solution
so our solution is U of X and y equals f
of X times G of Y now we can write U of
X and y equals a n times my function of
X which is Cinch of n PI over H X f of X
times my function of Y which is just a
nice clean oscillating sine n PI over H
Y G of Y and I can actually each of
these for every n for every positive
integer n these are each solutions of
Laplace's equation so I have a big sum
from N equals 1 to infinity right this
is true for N equals 1 2 3 4 this is a
linear equation so each of these
solutions adds up linearly and this is
the solution to my PDE extremely cool
it's just this infinite sum of basis
functions of orthogonal eigen functions
in x and y g of x is times f of x as x g
of wise why don't i have any cross terms
here why don't I have like sine H of 5
PI X and a sine of 4 PI Y
if there are a second albeit more well
they only multiply they only integrates
multiply to zero they don't multiply to
zero the reason is because our
fundamental separation of variables
assumption was that F X x over F equals
minus G UI y over G equals the same
constant so if this is you know N equals
5 then this has to be N equals 5 I can't
talk
you know 5s and fours or ends and ends
they have to be the same this is the
same constant here in here ok the last
thing we have to do this is this is a
super cool the last thing we have to do
is figure out what these coefficients
are okay and I fortunately actually
solved this before coming here I didn't
think I would get this far so last thing
is find a n to satisfy our last tricky
boundary condition ok the last ones the
hardest and now we're able to actually
solve for this boundary condition so in
the next lecture we're going to solve
Laplace's equation on a circular disk
which is kind of cool we're gonna code
up solutions to this four particular
boundary condition and plot it in MATLAB
see what it actually looks like and then
we're gonna start thinking about how we
would introduce Fourier transforms next
week I think I haven't quite decided
what I'd like to introduce Fourier
transforms because I'm about to do it
right now
so we're going to apply our boundary
condition on x equals L and that says
that U of L and y equals F of Y that
whatever the arbitrary function was my
boundary condition and so I have to plug
in L for X yep
so that equals the sum from N equals one
to infinity of a and cinch n PI L over H
times sine n pi Y over H this just has
to be true if my boundary condition is
satisfied and now we're going to
introduce the Fourier transform integral
trick and I'm going to integrate both of
these from 0 to H you can integrate this
from 0 to H so and I'm going to multiply
them both by sine of some other
frequency in Y this goes back to the
homework from 564 that showed that sine
of 5 PI over H Y is orthogonal to sine
of 4 PI over H Y on the interval 0 to H
ok so I have integral 0 to H of F of Y
sine M PI over H Y dy if this seems like
this comes out of nowhere it did this is
a hundred years later this came out of
seemingly nowhere Fourier figured out
that this is a really important thing to
do so I have my sum of a and sine n PI
over H Y that's this guy sine of M PI
over H Y that's this thing I multiplied
it by times Cinch of a number n PI L
over H this is just a number or constant
and from the homework we're going to
revisit this this integral is equal to 0
as long as n does not equal M these are
orthogonal functions they will integrate
to 0 their product will integrate to 0
unless n equals M so these are or are
orthogonal
probably missing an a if and doesn't
equal M and so the only way this cannot
be equal to zero is for n equal to M or
m equal to n and so this integral equals
a and H over 2 times this constant cinch
of n pi L over H this integral that I
made up I just cooked this up out of
nowhere for ei cook this up out of
nowhere equals this I mean actually
Bernoulli did this for ei formalized it
and made a whole theory about orthogonal
functions ok the last thing now we have
a function for a n so an equals 2 over H
cinch n PI L over H these are all just
numbers this is a number a N equals 2
over H Cinch times this integral
okay and I plugged in n in here because
I need this M to be equal to n okay so
this is the actual solution the full
solution that satisfies all of my
boundary conditions is this function
with these constants and I can get those
constants by taking my boundary
condition and just integrating it with a
bunch of orthogonal signs so I'm taking
my function and I'm writing it in a new
coordinate system in terms of these
orthogonal function signs we're gonna
talk about what that means later but
this gives me a basis for all functions
an orthogonal infinite dimensional
vector space basis for all functions and
this gives me the coordinates of F in
this sine wave basis okay that's all I
have for today tomorrow Friday we're
going to go through different boundary
conditions MATLAB and you know another
cool example no more super super
detailed math but this is like an
extremely important result this is the
basis of all Fourier transforms and how
we solve much much harder PDEs on
computers and by hands okay so this is
like the future of how to solve PDE s
alright that's it thank you
you